[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
lecture grandmaster's choice so in this
lecture I will be going over some games
that I have played recently and I hope
all of you will learn a lot from it and
I will be teaching all of you how to
outplay your opponent in the midle game
so welcome to everyone both here in the
classroom and online so the first game I
wanted to look at is this game I played
recently against darus SZ with white
pieces and this was played in the summer
chess classic here in St Louis now for
those of you who don't know St Louis
also hosts these Classics which are for
players rated over 2600 or maybe a
little bit below there and it's really
great that those tournaments take place
as it's great for me as I get to
practice or while I I get to play
against at least nine opponents of uh
similar strength all right so in this
game against Darius I open the game came
up with the move d4 my bread and butter
these days and kind of as I expected he
responded with the move Knight F6 C4 and
E6 so with these moves he's aiming to
play the the NIMS Indian defense which
arises after Knight C3 and Bishop B4 but
I went for something else I played the
move G3 the start of the Catalan now
Darius played D5 I played Bishop G2 and
here he surprised me a little bit with
the move Bishop to E7 Darius is also
taken on C4 he's played bishop4 check
he's played this in the past as well but
I wasn't necessarily prepare expecting
this for this game after Bishop B7 I
play Knight F3 kingside castles and here
by far and large White's main move is to
move kingside castles all black does
here is they take on C4 and after Queen
C2 white is going to get the pawn back
but in the process black is going to try
to activate this light squared Bishop
because in the Cataline very often the
advantage white has is the fact that
this bishop on G2 is more active than
this bishop on C8 so black does here is
they go A6 and in case I take they go B5
followed by Bishop B7 giving black a
fine game and if I go A4 to stop B5 then
Black Goes Bishop to D7 in in case I
take then Bishop C6 and now the bishop
is active over here but I played a
slightly different move I played the
move Knight C3 and I think before this
game Darius didn't really expect this
one and it's a move that is slightly
unpleasant to face if you you're
unprepared now Black's main move here is
taken on C4 and then white he goes
Knight E5 aiming to get the pawn back
and black can play C5 here there's
Knight C6 uh Queen D6 is also an option
but the thing is black has to know what
they're doing here black has to play
accurately for equality and that's
generally not a very pleasant uh place
to to be in you know if if you have to
find a bunch of accurate moves only to
reach an equal position so it's
understandable that Darius given the
fact that he might have might not have
checked his fils before this game they
not want to go into this he played the
move C6 solidifying this Pawn on D5 but
you know now white has the has more
space in the center so I castled and
here he played the move
A5 now you might be wondering what is he
trying to do with this move he's just
gaining space on the queen side for now
but also maybe later on he wants to go
B6 and Bishop um Bishop A6 bring the
bishop in that way and uh and and so on
and so forth here black also could have
taken on C4 but again I go Knight E5 and
black doesn't have a good way to hang on
to this Pawn let's say they go B5 I can
take over here and white wins a pawn as
the pawn on B5 is also hanging so
generally here white is considered to to
be slightly better again because this
bishop on C8 which is quite passive so
Darius played A5 now what white often
wants to do here is get in the E4 push
so I played this move B3 to just defend
the pawn on C4 right he played B6 and
now I played the move Knight to D2 with
this move I'm aiming to go for a quick
E4 push which again opens up my Bishop
on the long diagonal and here Darius
quickly played the move B5 but I wonder
if perhaps there's a chance he mixed up
something in his preparation because I
remember that B5 was a move after Knight
D2 and here B5 that is that black
gambits a pawn but after takes takes and
I take here Black Goes Queen B6 it
taking my knight the pawn on D4 let's
say I go Knight C3 they can they can out
take here and in case of A4 like it's
pretty good play with Bishop A6
attacking the Knight Knight C6 and and
so forth so play B3 with that to want to
bring my Bishop into the game so B6 and
the reason why I didn't play let's say
Bishop B2 here is that I think black can
now go let's say Bishop A6 attacking the
pawn and after Knight E2 perhaps now a
quick B5 putting more pressure and what
black wants to do
is bring this bishop to life again now
this bishop on E6 is not at all worse
than his Bishop on G2 so I wanted to
play E4 quickly so that's why I play
Knight D2 played
B5 all right and so uh here I really
don't think I have a lot of choice I
think I just have to take this Pawn over
here cuz if I go E4 now I think here
black is uh in pretty fine shape to just
take on C4 and take on D4 I think black
is just um doing fine here as the Knight
on C3 is also under attack so I accepted
a pawn sacrifice I took and now he
played Queen B6 so he's attacking my
knight and um yeah question to everyone
here in the classroom and in the
audience online how do we all think we
should deal with this move Queen B6 what
should we do our Knight's under attack
chess is all about decision making so
let me know what what do you think is
the right decision
here no worries no worries we're all
here to learn
you know we have someone in the chat
Caleb who's like 700 on chess.com but
he's found the right move so don't be
shy what do you think is the right move
Pawn A4 Pawn A4 is definitely move it
looks it's the first uh it's very
intuitive right you defend the Knight
because this Knight is defending this
Pawn over here but again Black Goes
Bishop A6 and then your knight is
hanging again and after black takes here
I think black is doing pretty fine even
if white gets the bishop air here the
bishop on G2 isn't too active the pawn
of B3 is a little bit weak and black
gets a pretty active position with a
knight coming to
C6 so okay four we see doesn't work out
in the right way so then what else can
we
do well the Knight is hanging
right mhm we see that protecting it is
possible black is fine over there there
right and we're playing it with the
white pieces so we want to try to get an
advantage out of the
opening with black often you're happy to
equalize with white you're hoping for an
advantage so if A4 is not the move what
else can be move
here don't be
shy C3 exactly Knight C3 excellent the
best move very good okay so black takes
this on D4 now the material is even our
Knight on C3 is hanging so how should we
deal with this what looks like a very
convenient way to deal with a threat on
the
Knight Bishop B2 Bishop B2 very good we
defend the Knight and develop another
piece oh you awesome now with the move
Bishop B2 we also create some threats
let's say black continues their
development with Bishop B7 Bish be7 is
not a good move but can anyone tell me
why what does why do
here
you see that with the move Bishop B2 we
not only develop our Bishop and protect
the Knight we also create this
battery 94 is possible you attack the
queen but the queen moves and yes she
can take over here and damage Black's
Pawn structure and White's probably
better here but it it's nothing too
terrible for black but why white is
something crushing here you're looking
in the right direction you see that you
can move the Knight out of the way and
attack the queen so then you think then
you got to think like hey do I
potentially have any Targets with that
Knight
this spawn over here yeah good ide all
right so why not so let's calculate so
Knight takes D5 what do you think
black's going to
do
where
D5 so let's see so Knight takes D5 Queen
takes D5 what does white do
there
also question everyone in the chat
Knight takes D5 Queen takes D5 what was
the move there
Knight exactly
yeah yep there's also this bishop over
here we can take the queen excellent
very good so it's very easy to just get
Tunnel Vision on this side of the board
on the N C3 and Bishop V2 but we got a
look at the full board and we also have
this bishop over here so indeed here
Knight Tak D5 is just crushing
we take the queen and the queen cannot
take as we take the queen and in case
the queen takes here at the very least
you know we can take on over here with
check the King has to move over and then
we win a piece let take this bishop over
here all right so Dario realized he had
to move the queen and I think around
here he the move he played was fine but
a big mistake he made was that he went
from 1 hour and 23 minutes on the clock
to 19 minutes and that came to haunt him
later on so the queen has to move and he
played the move Queen B4 a I move all
right so again he's stepping out of this
um this diagonal so what do we think we
should do here we have a slight lead in
development right with white we have
both Knights developed both
Bishops how do we continue from
here how do we use our pieces to their
full
potential
bring game or open up the bishop how can
you open up the bishop moving the Knight
on
okay so you open up that diagonal like
let's say you go I don't know like
Knight A4 right your Bishop is active
but it's not necessarily doing anything
the Knight is still protected so black
can play say Bishop A6 they're doing
pretty fine Rook C1 is fine as well
bringing another piece into the game but
black again play something like this and
they're doing quite
okay now here's the thing for the moment
the position the position is opened up
right some Pawns in the center are gone
but this bishop on G2 is a little bit
blocked in right now by the pawn on
D5 right and you especially take
advantage of a lead in development if
the position opens up even more so how
can we try to break open the position
here E4 exactly we go E4 excellent move
take this Pawn over here and we want to
open up the diagonal for this bishop
over here and also you know let's say
some trades happen over here then this
bishop also opens up right and we can go
for moves like Queen G4 threatning
Checkmate over here okay so Darius
played Bishop uh to
A6 and here I played the move A3 King
his Queen back play Queen B6 and now
what do we think we should do
here so move Bishop B6 black has
attacked to Rook on pH right what do we
think we should
do someone in the chat was asking was A3
accurate I think rookie one was slightly
more accurate but the reason I did not
go for rookie one is because of the move
Bishop to
C5 with with this move black is planning
to meet Pawn takes C5 with Bishop takes
F2
takes in Queen E4 I thought this was
okay for him but I think after Bishop
C5 if I'm not mistaken I think here
Queen F3 was good for me yes and I
thought he has Knight bd7 I think but
after something
like maybe it was E5 the position is
quite bad for for black so something
like this is what I what I should have
done anyway but I played A3 Queen B6 all
right so what do we do
here and hey not every move needs to win
the brilliancy price you're just playing
a game of chess again game of chess is
all about decision
making what do you what Rook E1 exactly
we just go Rook E1 a rook is hanging
there are ideas of taking over here but
I think black's just fine black can take
the Rook over here and um also you know
they're attacking our Bishop so stuff
like this doesn't ever work out so we're
going to have to recapture let's say
with the the queen and then black I
think is just fine after let's say takes
takes everything and I don't know Knight
C6 or Rook A7 it's not that easy for I
to prove the compensation
here all right so I played Rook E1 and
now what black played D4 attacking her
Knight on C3 so what should we do
here
what does everyone think we should
do now in chess you very often want to
gain the
initiative very often want to gain the
initiative with move d4 he's pushing me
around he's attacking my KN and I have
to respond to that
so it's nice to come up with a counter
punch that he has to respond to and then
I can keep making moves that that I want
to make and continue putting pressure on
him a so Knight A4 excellent we go here
and attack the
queen so we play Queen A7 to keep
hanging on to this Pawn on D4 all right
and now how do we continue how do we
continue our pressure
here
we don't want to let black of the
hook KN of3 is possible to increase the
pressure on Pawn on D4 but I think here
black
plays let me
think I think here black plays maybe D3
is all right I don't know if they can go
Knight C6 although feels like they can
probably take
here yeah it seems like Black's doing
fine there but I guess maybe maybe but
but KN F3 is a is a f Mo I think black
Black's doing fine for the moment after
D3 all right so any other ideas to
increase the pressure on
black I'm with Caleb in the chat yeah no
Caleb Caleb is on fire he's getting
better he's getting better
yeah
E5 exactly the move is E5 great job
Caleb and and Ben we tag this Rook over
here we also attack the Knight so black
only has one move like only as one move
let's also practice our defense what
should black play
here to hang on for the
moment how does black not lose
material because again your Knights on
attack and The Rook how can you hit two
birds with one stone and address both
threats excellent Knight E5 only move
all right so
kn5 and here I came up with the here I
came with a move that
was perhaps a little bit
surprising but I think it worked out
really well so what does everything what
does everyone think we should do here
we've got a pretty nice
position RPS are active black is not
fully developed yet this Knight is not
in the game yet this Rook therefore is
not in the game so if we can if we can
continue to pressure here it might be
tough for for black to to play this
position what ises every one thing we
should do
here
again chess is all about decision-
making and just like in life with every
decision you make there's always going
to be pros and cons you
know now I see a lot of people they want
to go Knight of C4 but I feel like
Knight C4 I can just play let's say
Knight C6 defend this Pawn over here and
it's not that clear how we're going to
follow up over here and overall Black's
got a position that is fundamentally
quite all right they've got this pass
Pawn over here maybe they can bring the
Rook into the game you know if black
gets the time they might be doing okay
here Queen G4 also has been suggested to
put pressure over here but black goes
Knight C6 and hangs on to the
pawn
mhm um four has been adusted in the chat
but it weakens this diagonal it weakens
the E3 Square so it isn't really the
move someone actually has suggested the
right idea in the
chat which is the move Bishop takes
D5 we give the bishop for the N now this
might look very strange very often this
bishop on G2 is white um I don't know
what know how to call it but like like
White's pride in the Catalan also if you
give this bishop you weaken the light
squares around your King right so you
got to got to find the right follow up
but I decided that this was all right
because after Pawn takes it's very
difficult for black to ever get let's
say a queen and a bishop on these light
squares right so we've given up our
Bishop black now has the double isolated
Pawns in the center how do we follow up
here how do we take advantage of those
weaknesses in the
center
now here's the thing especially with
double pawns especially the most forward
Pawn is the weak one right it's very
difficult to get to the pawn on
D5 right but the pawn on D4 is pretty
easy to
attack so how do we do that KN KN of
three excellent because KN of three and
we attack the pawn on D4 now perhaps o
Dario should have done here is play Move
Like Knight C6 but I just take here
whites up a pretty clean pawn and this
position is not a lot of fun for
black but he played D3 and now we also
see what why I gave him my Bishop for
the Knight on D5 I've given him this
bishop but this bishop over here has the
potential to become pretty strong in
this diagonal right now it's open and if
I push with this E Pawn it's already
looking at the G7 Pawn okay so how do we
continue from here black plays D3
hanging on to the pawn and again if
black gets the time to develop with a
move like Knight C6 there're doing quite
all right so what do we do
here
so E6 has been suggested by some people
in the chat but black goes Knight C6
they don't have to respond to this so
takes takes and I'd say this trade has
worked out in Black's favor as now the
pawn on F2 is under pressure and maybe
White's just maybe White's even worse
here already Rook A8 is coming and I
don't see a good way to to hang on to uh
the n on F3 mhm so Bishop D4 also a
possibility to attack the queen but I
think the problem is that black
plays let me think I think they just
move the
queen maybe they just play something
like Queen
B7
yeah I think black might just be fine
after let's say queen
B7 you can go Knight B6 but here maybe
black goes let's say Rook A7 and in case
you take they can take and here the weak
dark squares definitely are a factor
after let's say Bishop B7 right here the
bishop and the Queen and Bishop come to
life and that's exactly what I wanted to
avoid like right here they're still
super far away from ever doing any
damage to my king but in position we saw
right here they are doing damage on the
long diagonal and that's not what we
want so as some people have suggested in
the chat a great move is Knight D4 we
just stop black from playing Knight C6
this Knight is headed to F5 putting
pressure on the bishop also putting
pressure on this Pawn over here if E6
comes the Knight and Bishop are
cooperating perfectly also the queen can
always come to G4 so that's what I was
aiming for but really just the fact that
this Knight cannot come into the game
let's say black goes Knight D7 white has
a way here to win the game on the spot
white what does white do
here why just has a knockout punch
here why is Knight D7 not a good
move
C6 mhm so what do we do Knight C6 Knight
C6 excellent attacking the queen and we
pick up the bishop all right so Knight
E7 is not possible which is a pretty big
problem for black so black played
G6 all right now here there are multiple
good moves White's got a pretty dominant
position again like the black pieces can
really
move so I played Queen G4 bringing my
queen into the attack as well okay okay
now black played Queen to B7 so with
Queen B7 they want to go Knight C6 they
really want to get this Knight into the
game if black gets another move here
they're not doing too bad again Knight
D7 is not a move because of Knight D6
but so Queen B7 what do we do now with
white exact which
Pawn yep we go E6 excellent we go E6 we
want to open up this diagonal for our
Bishop and do some damage to the black
king now Rook ac1 has been suggested in
the chat but Rook A1 is not a good move
what does black play
here
they go D2 yep and they have a fork so
that's not the right move okay so I
played E6 opening up this diagonal and
it's really tough for black to uh to
survive here especially because darios
was getting very long time now he played
the move Knight to C6 but Knight C6
actually lose the game by
force so does so let's let's calculate
here a little bit and let's find a let's
try to find a win here for white there
are multiple good moves but but what do
we all think let's calculate everyone
here in the chat and in
person I I'll help you guys out a little
bit it would be great to take advantage
of this long diagonal right would be
great to take advantage of the long
diagonal I'll give you guys another hint
very often black can close the long
diagonal with F6 like let's say
something like Knight F5 looks pretty
tempting but I think here black still
goes F6 white is certainly better but I
don't see knockout punch just
yet all right so what do we think and
it's not a one move it's not a one move
um
solution it is wait let's see one two
three it's actually combination of four
moves but you have to put all of the
different themes
together
[Music]
MH so what do we all
think PA takes F7 Pawn takes F7 is a
good start take here black recaptures
with the Rook now the one thing though
is that if you take a s you should
already have some followup in mind
because this improves the placement of
The Rook black is eyeing this Pawn on
F2 um so what do we do
now
queen6 Queen E6 is possible but it
doesn't actually create a threat right
so after Queen E6 black can
play um I mean the Knight is hanging but
black can I don't know take over here
maybe play
D2 Black's actually doing very fine I
mean they can also take over here like's
very much in the
game so you want to create threats Queen
E6 and he takes KN black can just
take and you want to get to that King
somehow
right F C7 has been suggested but black
just
recaptures so that's not the way to
go I'll help you guys out a little bit
we see that putting the queen on E6 is
not very effective right but if we could
somehow get the queen Queen on this
diagonal oh wait sorry on the long
diagonal together with the bishop that
could be pretty deadly cuz Queen H would
be made so getting the queen on the long
diagonal would be
great so how do we get
there okay we can take the Knight black
recaptures let's take go Queen E4 right
we threaten mate does black still have a
defense here
mhm yep exactly Bishop to F6 very
good so black goes Bishop F6 and blocks
the
diagonal and black again is doing pretty
fine here now a lot of people in the
chat have suggested Rook takes E7
followed by Queen Queen D4 this is
possible but but Queen
h8 it's not made King can still move up
so I'm not a big fan of this I think
here like a maybe just play let's say
D2 I mean you can check but the king
moves up you can check but the King goes
here or here and it's a pretty in clear
position black is turning Rook e one in
the meantime so I'm not not a big fan of
this
one so we see what we want to do right
we want to put that Queen on the on the
long diagonal but we want to make sure
that black does not have a defense we
want to make sure that black does not
have Bishop
F6 so what can we do here to make sure
that black does not have to move Bishop
F6
so people in the chat have found it
indeed here we have the move Rook to E6
excellent attacking the queen and now
when our Queen moves here he cannot stop
this and you know when I was calculating
was like Rook e six he's no way of
stopping this like cannot go here or
here and um yeah let's say by the way
black plays Bishop to
C8 what do we do here with
white what do we do here with white
yeah here would just go Queen to D4 cuz
we turn Checkmate anyway don't take the
queen and there's nothing black can do
all right so Rook E6 and yeah Black's in
big trouble black played Queen C2 and
what do we do
now the nice thing is everything per
coordinates perfectly here for
white someone in the chat suggested
Queen E4 but it hangs the queen it's a
little bit
unfortunate so what do the move here for
white also by the way black is is
threatening this Pawn on
F2 exactly so we go Queen E4 excellent
and it works out beautifully for white
we defend the pawn on F2 we thr checkm
it over here there's no Bishop F6 so
black just resigned the black's best
move is Queen digs F2 which tells you
how bad Black's position is because
black just goes down and rook in an end
game and this is completely lost so yeah
we see a pretty nice game here uh and
how we can use our slight lead in
development to never give black a chance
to get into into the game now darius's
big mistake was that he never really
accepted a slightly worse position and
let's say this position right here he
should have at some point just taken on
e4 now White's going to be a bit better
here after let's say um takes takes cuz
I've got these these Bishops that are
pretty active but you know it isn't too
terrible for for black but again the
mistake that he made is that he kept
playing to to principal with moves like
D4 and now cuz here if black gets some
time with like Knight C6 or E5 they're
doing pretty okay but they don't get
that time all right so and for for those
you wondering in the chat this was my
game against Darius SZ from the summer
chess classic approximately uh a month
ago all right so now let's have a look
at another game this was played in the
spring classic and I was playing with
the black pieces now I just came from a
win with the white pieces the day before
against Sam savian so I was on 50% and
um yeah so I I got uh you know better in
in the tournament but okay so he my
opponent played the move E4 I played E5
Knight F3 Knight C6 and he played Bishop
B5 the real lope pass okay so I played
A6 Bishop A4 and I played to move Knight
F6 attack developing my knight and he
played the move D3 now I think with the
move D3 He just wanted to make it very
easy for himself because uh with the
move D3 you know you don't have to uh
reckon with the open
Spanish and you're already in this D3
system so to speak like black can go B5
here they can go D6 but there's not a
lot of systems you have to know but okay
I play Bishop C5 no question to everyone
when the move D3 white is defending this
Pawn over here right so let's say white
takes on C6 and takes on E5 what does
black play
here it's not a good idea for why to
take this Pawn but how do we punish it
what does black play here mhm good job
Dre yep indeed here black plays the move
Queen to D4 turning Checkmate on F two
and attacking the Knight on E5 okay so
my opponent just castled now this is a
threat as the F2 Pawn is protected it's
no longer threatening checkmate
so I play B5 Bishop B3 and D6 you know
solidifying my Center my opponent played
A4 threatening to take as my Rook on A8
is undefended so play Rook B8 okay so he
took took played C3 and here at here I
had a decision to make I can I can
Castle here but then there's a move
Bishop G5 that I have to reckon with I
can also go H6 to make sure that that is
not a move but then he has to move d4
and eventually I decided the castle but
but quite quickly I regretted it a
little bit as he played Bishop G5 quite
quickly pinning my knight on F6 so I
played H6 Bishop G5 and after some
thought I played the move G5 and I
thought okay well I take his Bishop he
has to move the bishop back and then
I'll thing would I'll do like will I go
let's say Bishop G4 maybe King G7 it
feels like black should be doing fine
here my king side has been weakened a
little bit but I've got a pretty active
position this bishop on G3 is also a
little bit uh locked but instantly he
played the move Knight G5 and I'm like
oh well great like apparently I run into
some
preparation all right okay I took he
takes and here I played the move King G7
so play King G7 with the idea to protect
the Knight on
F6 right because now he goes Queen F3 to
put more pressure on it so I had to play
this move at some
point cuz the thing is if I get the time
to let's say go like Knight E7 to G6 I'm
doing pretty fine so that's why he
increases the pressure now white has two
pawns here for the Knight but again this
pin is pretty unpleasant and it's not
that easy for me to move because let's
say I play something like Bishop B6 I
would love for white a take as then you
know my Rook defends Knight and this
alleviates a lot of the pressure but
after Bishop B6 white plays let's say
Bishop D5 attacking my knight which is
not that easy to deal with I don't have
Knight E7 like let's say I take he
recaptures my knight again is hanging
and I think this might already be quite
bad after let's say Knight E2 and Knight
E4 so so why's got real compensation
here for the for the piece okay so I
played Rook h8 I play Rook h8 bring my
Rook into the game you play Bishop D5
attacking my knight now how does
everyone think is what is the best way
to deal with the threat on our
Knight
what is the best way to do with the
threaten our
Knight yep indeed we just go Bishop D7
just to protect the Knight I mean
there's no other good way to protect it
like let's say you go Rook B6 B before
our Bishop is trapped we cannot move the
Knight so just have to go Bishop D7 mhm
so white play B4 attacking the bishop
all right now what what should we do
now now this bishop is on our
attack and some of these moves like
Bishop D7 are not that difficult right
but I'm trying to make you guys play the
game here as black like your Bishop was
under attack what do you
do
well indeed we just have to move the
bishop back we just go Bishop B6 it's
the only Square for the bishop all right
now here my opponent played the move
Knight to A3 so the move Knight A3 he's
putting pressure on this Pawn over here
but what why would also love to do is go
like Knight C2 the E3 to bring the
Knight over there and once the Knight
lands on E3 I can never really take as
white recaptures with the F Pawn and
this opens up the foul for the rook and
my knight on F6 comes under even more
pressure and also with the Knight on E3
let's make a couple of moves I play
Queen E7 Knight C2 let's say I play I
don't know Rook B G8 right it's a move I
can considered he goes Knight E3 and now
I have to be extremely careful cuz if I
go let's say I don't know his his threat
is to take here and go Knight F5 check
so my Bishop no longer controls that
square so with the Knight coming to E3
things get pretty
scary and I didn't like this position at
all I felt like you know I'm up a piece
but I'm under a lot of pressure it's
very difficult for me to make a move but
here I found a way to change the
momentum of the game the move I
played I I don't know if it's
necessarily the best move I think it was
one of the best moves actually but I
really liked it from a practical point
of view because again it it changed the
momentum of the game
completely
so what can black do here we're going to
have to be a little bit creative here
black has move here to again change the
change the pace of the game to change
the
momentum Rook H6 has been suggested in
the chat it's actually
uh a move that that's quite
decent white can take but here at least
you're out of the pin but I think even
here it's not that Pleasant after let's
say Knight E3 and the Knight is coming
to F5 thing white definitely keeps an
initiative
here you're going to have to be a little
bit creative here to find the move that
I came up came up with G4 not really a
move as why can take here and then take
the bishop we lose the the
piece maybe move the Knight
to uh move this Knight the other H
Knight d8 yeah knight8 is possible but
why goes Knight E3 anyway and like now
we can go C6 but the bishop moves back
here and now I mean there's also moves
like Rook A6 with
pressure
right Bishop E6 but uh White doesn't
have to take and also this is not a
threat as there's Knight a five so and
maybe here why can take or I don't know
if why it's so eager to take but again
all of this isn't very it's not very
it's not a very pleasant position for
for black like there's Rook A6 and it
still remains very difficult to move
right I mean if I take there's here you
don't want to take here because there's
this so it's very difficult to move so
the move I came up with
was Knight takes
D5 I'm sacking my queen but keep in mind
that I've already won a piece right so
here I actually have three minor pieces
for the queen I've got two Bishops and a
knight but white also has two pawns
right so white has the material
advantage because the queen is
considered to be worth nine points and
every minor piece is considered to be
worth three so the the queen and
the well the in term the the Queen the
queen and the minor piece is even out
but he's got these two extra pawns right
but at least here you know my pieces can
move again all right because I've got
these these open files that I can now
try to use to my advantage so he played
the move
d4 which I think was a was a fine
move and um I the Deep answer your
question the computer actually um
thought this was completely fine it was
actually one of the best
moves now what do we do here after D4
how do we continue bringing our pieces
into the
game how do you how do we all think we
should deal this D4
push
kn6 I guess you mean Knight
G6 9 G6 is a is a is a fine idea with
the move with the idea that in case it
goes D5 now go Knight C7 that's
definitely something I considered but it
didn't like Knight G6 go to move Knight
E3 and it's a little bit unpleasant I
can go here or here and if I take I
think K goes Knight D5 and he now has to
move Queen F6 so I didn't quite like
this so the move that I played is to
move Rook H6 so we see we're not at all
forced to take over
here um and here he played check all
right so how do we all think we should
deal with this
check also by the way white could have
played D5 here but I thought it here I'm
doing quite okay after let's say Knight
d8 it can go F6 Knight F7 this Knight
can go here this other Rook can swing in
and again at least practically it's it's
a lot more fun to play with
black okay so who gave this check the
check looks weird some people have
pointed out in the chat yeah like a lot
of people okay this looks weird but
we'll see the idea
soon so here indeed we just block with
the rook and he played Queen E3
defending the pawn so how do we continue
bringing more pieces into the
game do we continue bring more pieces
into the
game and indeed the idea we'll see very
shortly is to go F4 to try to open up
that F first
Rook so what do we do here with
black
mhm uh Rook G8 is possible yeah but I
would still have to move mying k out of
the way Rook G definitely a good move I
played Rook h8 just bring the Rook into
the game right away cuz the thing is
also let's say you go here I guess I'll
have to move the king here because if I
go here then there's this check um but
yeah it's def definitely possible to go
here but I played rook h8 and here he
played F4 aiming to open up on the king
side so how do we all think we should
deal with this move cuz you know he
wants to open up the foul F5 is also
annoying attacking a rook and bringing
ideas of F6 into
position so what do we all think we
should
do you can move
the
queen a rook H3 yes yeah we going Rook
H3 and attack the queen but I think here
white just yeah Rook H3 actually makes a
lot lot of
sense let me think I think here white
plays maybe it was just
G3
or this move was definitely possible but
I wasn't
too impressed with
it um maybe it's just
G3
G3 F5 certainly a possibility as well
Bishop H3 is a move but I think might
just goes Rook F2 mhm so I took on D4
took on D4 because I want to make sure
that this bishop remains active over
here right you the diagonal exactly this
this spin on the diagonal is pretty
unpleasant for him because you know I
also have pressure on these files so
he's got to be a little bit uh careful
all right so took with a nine which was
quite a critical mistake I thought
actually during the game that it made
made sense but he should have taken with
the pawn that's what he should have
done okay so he takes to the
Knight okay now what what do we do
here what is the way to go with
black I'll help you I'll help everyone
out we'll take here first okay
now so here you just have to think like
okay white wants to go F5 attack a rook
and go F6 which would create a deadly
Fork on our King and Knight so what do
we do
here you have to move the Knight and try
to attack the pawn in the center because
he spin you pressure okay we can go
Knight C6 but right defensive with rook
ad1 and here still a five is
coming just not that easy to deal with
as possible but indeed better is the
move F5 stopping F5 altogether okay five
green move and here white played Rook A6
and with the move this is the move white
was banking on White's idea is to take
here give up The Rook for the bishop but
after I take the pressure here is gone
right so let's say I play a move like I
don't know um I'm just going to make um
let's say do this he wants to take and
then go D5 Bishop is gone there's no
more any pressure here here I've got a
lot of pieces for the queen I've got two
Rooks a knight and a bishop but white
again has a lot of Pawns this Pawn is
week my king is a little bit exposed
Queen E4 is coming my pieces don't
really coordinate here and White's at
least doing fine here White's probably
just better but after Rook
A6 I found a great way to make sure that
my pieces do come to
life so what do we do here with black
got to again if white gets the time to
take on B6 and go D5 they're doing quite
fine they're probably better yeah maybe
you have to push the the center try to
defend with a rook right D5 is possible
but um here maybe white just takes and
then there's Queen E5 check after was
not
too because he had
check he had Che
mhm
again it's a little bit it's a little
bit passive we want to make sure that
our Pieces come to
life and here I I found a little
tactical
sequence sorry what did you take no I
didn't take the
pal mhm so someone has suggested the
right move in the chat I play Bishop C6
with this move I want to take here and
if I take here then all of a sudden all
of my pieces coordinate perfectly now he
can go D5 as the pawn is pinned right I
mean E5 hangs made um so like if I take
here then there's also like
knight5 now what happens in case white
takes here and perhaps this is what he
missed what do we do
here take with the bishop exactly we
take here with the bishop now we
threaten to take here like let's say mov
The Rook this is check and made he
cannot do that and so then he has to
play let's say Rook
F2 well or or just take here take yeah
we can just take and here we have two
Rooks a knight and we have a rook a
knight and a bishop for the queen which
is more than enough and our pieces
coordinate
perfectly that is the big difference and
we managed to capture a very important
Pawn so here he realized he was in
trouble so played Rook F3 I took KN
played Rook
G3 and I played Knight D5 putting my
knight in the middle all right so here
it's all working together very nicely
for for black okay so he played Queen E2
and now I brought my Rook into the game
with Rook to H4 attacking this one over
here which is not that easy to protect
he can play G3 but then I think I can
just go Rook H3 Follow by here and here
so if white plays slowly if white plays
passively they're going to lose the game
slowly because the thing is I can always
attack his
weaknesses and uh let's say he would
give up his Queen for the the the bishop
for the rook in the Knight I should be
winning in the end game with my two
Bishops Against The Rook all right so he
sacked he sacked over here and brought
his Queen into the game like maybe
Knight H was better but okay took the
pawn went Queen C1 I brought my Rook
back played Queen C6 and I played Rook
to D to defend the pawn on
D6 so he played
H3 playing KN of six to attack the queen
and now he took over here so how do we
uh continue our Rook is on attack where
should we go with the Rook we want to
activate the Rook
right you have to move the and
then what the Rook is hanging oh
sorry
so want to bring the rook in
now so Rook eight definitely possible I
played Rook to C8 because I want to go
Rook to C2 and
here you know black is definitely better
black is pushing for the win white maybe
had to take on D6 and it's it's pretty
unpleasant but there's still chance to
hold but he played G4 which loses on the
spot now I'll help you guys out a little
bit I took over here but what does black
play in this position yeah you have to
play you have to play The Rook and
control you don't want he takes
the the pawn you know so then you going
to block with the Rook so you attack the
queen Rook C6 is possible but he plays
let's say
queen let me think
queen d8 or
something that's not quite the move the
move actually is Knight takes G4 take
this pawn and now this king is all of a
sudden trapped my Bishop covers D
squares my knight covers D squares so
Rook C1 would be made he takes and now I
go King H5 and all of a sudden he
doesn't have a single check on my king
this is not available this is not
available and this is not available so
he has to go king of
one all right now how do we keep closing
in the Escape squares around the
king
King is really trapped over here
right we can go Rook C2 but why goes
let's say queen E7 taking our Bishop
threatening M and it's not that easy for
a way to deal
with so in indeed the move for black is
the move Bishop F3 taking away the
Escape SC for the white king okay so he
played King E1 and now I play Rook to C2
and I want to give this check over here
which is quite
deadly
um Rook C2
check and yeah this king is uh cuz if he
goes here he's getting he's going to get
check made it and if goes here then I
should always have a discovery so played
Queen
E7 played rookie to check take take take
and now what do we do here we have this
end game where we have the king and the
Knight and one Pawn we only have to keep
one Pawn on on the board but we have to
make sure the king doesn't somehow step
up so how do we keep white Under
Control well deeps was saying he said
like I need like an hour to calculate
this game well that's why this was a
classical game so I I did have the
time
so indeed we go Knight F6 stopping D5
King
E3 and now I played King G4 bringing my
king in he goes
D5 question do we take this Pawn yes or
no and if white can somehow get that
King in they're making a draw they
escape shape do we take the pawn yes or
no what do we think in the
chat I don't know we have to make the
sequence because you took the pawn he's
coming with the queen with the King and
then you protect you protect no no no
you we can go here but he goes
here yeah and yeah so we don't take the
pawn indeed we keep shouldering the king
we go King F5 let's see why goes King D4
what do we do here this is you have to
avoid to the to the king comes and then
you have to use the Knight so how do we
do that yeah so you move
two2 D7 D7 yeah yeah so I think both are
fine I wasn't 100% sure about 94 because
they're still
D6 and then yeah know wait in case I
take there's King D5 no wa wait here
there's Knight C4 Knight C4 by the way
and Knight E3 and he
wins uh if here but there's no no this
is actually a draw cuz he goes F5 and
F6 and my king keeps getting distracted
so inde the only winning move is Knight
to D7 because D6 I'm just in time and if
he doesn't do that and let's say he sits
the here winning plan is pretty
straightforward I just bring my King
around and eventually I pick up
everything so instead of all that he
played King D3 I took the pawn now we're
Knight E4 takes Stakes King C5 King E5
and he resigned or cuz if he goes here
go King
E4 and yeah that's it so I managed to
win this game with a black piece is very
important win and that also helped me on
the way to winning the spring chess
Classic this year but yeah everyone did
great both here in the classroom and in
the chat I hope all of you all of you
guys enjoy watching make sure to tune in
tomorrow I will be uh uh doing another
lecture in the evening and so I hope to
see all of you guys for
[Music]
[Applause]
that the world's most unpredictable
chess is back chess 9 LX makes its
return to the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri beginning September
7th 10 players will compete for a
$150,000 prize fund with 960 different
variations even the best in the world
don't know what's coming featuring Gary
Kasparov takaro Nakamura and returning
Champion Fabiano kowana this is an event
you won't want to miss catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch Channel
s